this wasn't your first time meeting  Jennifer Aniston that was my first time  but then I went to dinner at her house  after the the we finished the shoot I  was in LA about maybe a month later and  she very kindly invited me to her lovely  house and we had to dinner with her  friends and I still get starstruck I  mean I even look into that then I think  anyway so having dinner and I'm staying  cool so it's great ever he's lovely  doorbell rings Lisa Kudrow comes in with  her husband and I'm like okay Rachel and  Phoebe are in the room now keep your  hand off the mobile phone she said  [Applause]  you know it's I think it's quite nice to  still have those pinch-me moments you  know I never never gets normal this  industry in this business and you know  for a moment I was just sitting between  Rachel and Phoebe and they were having a  chat Wow  [Music]